I want to play a game what's on your  phone what's on my bullets on your phone  ok what is one app that people will be  surprised to know is on your phone oh I  don't have any that weren't any app that  was it for uh what do you call it up uh  the one that gives you directions oh is  it you ways or the map there's like just  the Google no just a Google map but I  oh my gosh you're gonna get neither view  you got that nice look I have a call  hold on view Craig called me while we're  sitting here yeah but I hate turn off so  I'm gonna try to put an app on this okay  guys I use the phone  I call and that's it you know that's all  you need you know come on go nonsense I  love it I don't have the Google now